Welcome to another video in my series on
sound changes when I'm sharing the ways
that sounds change over time
in languages I've covered,
sounds becoming more or less similar
and sounds getting added or deleted.
This time I'll highlight a few other
sound change types starting with
[inaudible],
which means that a sound is weakened,
it becomes more voiced or less restricted.
This weakening often
happens adjacent to other,
less restricted sounds
like vowels or fricatives.
The ignition is potentially a
multistep process of United sound.
Might simply go from voiceless to voice
or plosive to fricative will have fully
lineated sound disappears all together.
The Spanish stop the is limited
to a fricative the between valves,
so this word is fun analogically Dow,
those most speakers
glide past this middle,
the with even less restricted airflow.
Davos some speakers take the [inaudible]
step further by omitting the entirely
douse.
The path of this llanishen was voiced,
stopped to voiced fricative to
voiced approximate to nothing.
There are two main paths alumni did sound
may go down if the sound and question
goes from a stop to a fricative to an
approximate like the Spanish one did.
This process of relaxing the airflow
is called opening. For instance,
Tuscan Italian speakers
soften co two a fricative,
so they'll scan gets pronounced Toscano
if the sound goes from voiceless to
voiced and then becomes progressively less
restricted,
it's called [inaudible].
We can see sooner realization if we
extend the timeline for the Spanish word
Davos I gave before.
That word descends from
a Latin word that toes,
you can see a clear example of [inaudible]
in this progression that those two
dot dose to Davos to dominoes to Dallas.
When sounds get weaker.
Becoming more like voiced approximates,
we call it [inaudible].
What about sounds?
Getting stronger towards voiceless stops.
That happens too and
it's called [inaudible].
Strengthening turns a less restricted
sound like an approximate or fricative
into a more restricted one
like an African or a stop.
As a simple example that you sound in,
you is fortified to an affricate Jay in
the colloquial pronunciation did you?
As [inaudible].
I'm going to move on to a handful
of other sound change types.
So start making a list.
Don't fear though.
I'll give simple explanations and
examples of each one along the way.
If a consonant is deleted,
but the vowel before it is length,
and to make up for that loss,
it's called compensatory lengthening.
The protal Greek word, [inaudible]
foot eventually lost. It's Duh,
but ancient Greek speakers lengthen the
vowel ow to compensate for that loss.
So their word for foot was bowls,
not just both.
Speaking of the Greeks,
if two or more sound swap places that
has a fun Greek name metathesis in the
nonstandard pronunciation of ask as acts,
the two consonants and Sir get switched.
Similarly,
Sardinian speakers say four bolt instead
of the expected Dato inherited from
Latin towed,
or
if one or more vowels change to become
like another valve within the same word,
it's pleasantly called vowel harmony.
Two examples here.
First, the easier one. Turkish
builds words by tacking on endings,
but the vowels in those endings harmonize
with the last val in the root word
that they attached to. So the
Turkish, now ev means house.
And the pluralist avalanche houses
where the plural ending has the matching
vowel, eh, but the plural of be
not building is be not allowed.
Within a second example, the vowel Ah,
in the Proto Germanic word for people
was raised and fronted to eh in men under
the influence of the high front
vowel in the next syllable,
this change towards a high front
vowel is called [inaudible].
In the history of the Germanic
languages like English,
I'll cover one more change here.
We looked at stress and pitch acts
and in the IPA for language learning,
if the way a language accent
syllables changes over time,
the name for that is an accent shift.
Early Indo European languages stress
different syllables in different words,
which shows up in the way
Sanskrit and Greek accent,
the last syllable in
it does or [inaudible],
but the first syllable in mythos or Mithid
Germanic languages like English have
fixed the stress accent
to the first syllable.
And this accent shift explains why the
English equivalents of those words our
father and mother both stressed
on the initial syllable.
In just a few short videos,
you've been able to arm yourself
with the range of sound change types,
but instead of longwinded pros,
can we capture the sound
changes in concise formulas?
The video,
we'll tie up this series by showing
you the most common and traditional way
linguists visualize the sound changes
that I've explored in this series.